my name is abdul tajuri i work as a
weaver making traditional products with
cotton on this loom
i have this shop in the old city in an
area called the four columns and i work
alone
this loom is one of the older ones in
the late 1940s and 50s
newer models came on the market using
silk and other materials
but this one uses cotton i'm now
continuing this craft
my grandfather taught my father and he
taught me
but as for the new generation few have
learned
uncle abdullah was a weaver but after he
passed away his shop closed
and it's still empty because he didn't
teach anyone we should teach this craft
so it's passed on from generation to
generation
and won't die out but it's a dying
tradition
it's been neglected i tried to open a
school for decades under gaddafi's
government but nothing happened
this government has promised me it will
help me open a school for traditional
crafts like weaving
it's allocated as space for us we can
move into it in march
as for me i hope our country becomes
better and this craft doesn't die
i welcome anyone who wants to learn and
i hope to teach at the school
so the generations to come can enjoy
making traditional crafts
through weaving